hier bei uns ist der gaspreis weiter das
große sorgen thema millionen deutsche
schauen auf ihn robert habeck was macht
er jetzt mit seinem murks gesetz zur
kassenlage die kann doch eigentlich weg
oder patricia jetzt die gasanlage die
wahl beschlossen worden um vor allem
juni per zu retten aber unser staat hat
ja mit steuergeld jetzt juni per
komplett gekauft den
gasimporteur also kann die gasanlage
doch weg oder robotik nein sagt der und
regt sich richtig drüber auf über alle
die sagen die umlage muss weg
auf der zunge zergehen lassen was dieses
land erlebt und das hören wir von der
opposition und das ist der eigentliche
punkt die gasanlage
sind wir denn hier im fußballstadion
oder was ist das mit dem bus steckt sie
sind die buslenker positionen konnten
sie das für eine antwort kommen sie mit
man dass wir alles nicht gezündet das
ich mir wünschen dass alles wetten muss
aber das ist doch keine politik was
kommt denn statt dessen was ist denn die
antwort darauf und wenn sie schon wenn
sie sich schon entschieden haben nicht
konstruktive opposition zu sein dann
sollten sie wenigstens die traute haben
zu ihren eigenen anträge auf wahrheit
und ausdruck zu geben und das tun sie
nämlich nicht natürlich gibt es eine
möglichkeit anderes geld aufzunehmen
sondern müssen sich hier herstellen und
sagen statt der gasanlage wollen wir
jetzt sofort etwa 35 milliarden euro
aufnehmen oder in unternehmen
kapitalisieren das tun sie aber nicht
sie stellt sich hin mit klumpen
forderungen dann sagen sie wenigstens
ehrlich und diesel diese listig im süden
die ernsthaft
sie wollen
entschieden ich sage nicht dass es der
richtige
[Musik]